[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le cas où vous l'ignoreriez il est
né le divine enfant alors à vous tous
joyeux Noël joyeux Noël à
tous joyeux Noël mesdames joyeux Noël
mesdemoiselles joyeux Noël messieurs et
vous tous les enfants qui nous avvez
fait l'honneur d'assister à ce music and
music spécialement spécialement destiné
à votre intention et on ne peut pas
mieux commencer he Stéphane qu'en
accueillant sur scène les popies avec la
marche de Mickey les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
popies
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ut tenre
Ponz tousz chanter
[Musique]
àre le patron du club où tout le monde
r bienven
[Musique]
à il fa
tenirreter
[Musique]
allons-y
marchonsantons dans la
[Musique]
nuit nous
[Applaudissements]
jouonsck
z tous VZ
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
àz VZ chter à
venez tous venez chanter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à chanter àre C
[Musique]
bravo merci au poppies et à cette marche
avec tous ces personnages de Walt Disney
que nous adorons et la participation
exceptionnelle de colaro le canard un
personnage de Walt Disney aussi c'est
que quand je danse avec l'oiseau qui a
un grand nez ma femme n'est pas jalouse
donc c'est vraiment on peut y aller
c'est très avantageux et c'est vrai moi
je trouve qu'il dansait très très bien
ah oui vous avez été remarquable et bien
mesdames et messieurs nous accueillons
une surprise une surprise une surprise
de
qualité puisque très
gentiment pour une
œuvre merveilleuse puisque c'est une
œuvre qui s'occupe spécialement des
enfants ce sont pour les c'est une œuvre
qui s'occupe des enfants du Chili de
ceux qui n'ont là-bas au Chili peut-être
pas de quoi s'acheter à manger quelques
artistes français don George brassin
Jean ferat Greco Maxime Le Forestier
Collette Mannie maki mouudji y montant
rjan Francesca Solville et Anne
Sylvestre on fait un disque pour les
enfants du Chili pour que eux aussi est
un Noël je qu'il y a une chose
formidable c'est que chaque fois qu'un
de ces disques est vendu bien ça fait h
repas de Noël pour les enfants du Chili
h donc c'est un disque je crois qu'on
peut acheter parce que d'abord il n a
que des gens de qualité dessus et
ensuite c'est une faire une bonne œuvre
et parmi toutes ces vedettes il y en a
un qui nous a fait l'amitié une pardon
qui nous a fait l'amitié de venir ce
soir passer cette soirée de Noël avec
nous Julien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
claire je voudrais
m'éveiller jeune bébé plié
dans le ventre de sa mère tirer mes très
longs
drap sur ma tête
bouclée et dire que rien ne
va je voudrais
écouter tous les bruits de la rue et la
conversation de la pluie sur le toit en
me disant tout
bas je ne me lèai pas juste comme un
homme
juste comme un
enfant juste comme un
enfant comme un
enfant je voudrais
déboucher une bouteille de vin en boire
la moitié et puis verser le reste dans
le creux de terrain pour voir si tu dors
bien je voudrais
allumer une vraie
cigarette oublier le cendrier et mettre
le feu au lit tu poussera sûrement enfin
un cri
surpris juste comme une
enfant juste comme une
enfant comme une
enfant je voudrais siflootter un air
désespéré pendant qu'un beau voisin
t'emporterait très loin évanoui et serré
dans sa veste de cuire je voudrais
continuer mon sommeil
abrégé et me brûler les peds tout en me
récitant croix de bois croix de fer si
je Meur c'est
l'enfer juste comme un
enfant juste comme un
enfant comme un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en merci merci merci à toi d'être venu
d'être venu si gentiment et aussi
simplement chanter comme ça avec avec un
piano parce que c'était prendre un
risque énorme et merci de l'avoir pris
pour pour cette re comment s fait disque
ben on nous a demandé on a reçu des
papiers qui nous demandaient si on
voulait faire amener notre participation
pour les enfants du Chili et ben j'ai
dit oui et ben c'est très bien on
applaudit très très fort Julien claire
et bon Noël Julien Jacques on peut l' pe
dire d'autant plus que on lui a
téléphoné hier pour lui demander de
venir et je crois qu'il est plus attaché
encore à faire la la promotion de ce
disque làà que de ses propres albums et
oui parce qu'il est en train de préparer
son disque il aurait été en droit de
nous dire euh je suis pas libre non il
est venu alors ça c'est formidable et ça
prouve que voyez-vous dans notre petit
milieu des artistes il existe quand même
une forme de cœur qui ne nous déplaît
pas et bien ce sont des fidèles de
l'émission et je crois que les enfants
présents dans la salle vont être heureux
puisque je sais qu'il compte parmi les
favoris de la jeunesse française qui est
là ce soir représenté en grand nombre
donc sur le plateau de music and music
dans une chanson intitulé bibliquement
les 10 commandements nous accueillons
nos amis les Martins
[Applaudissements]
Circus et la dan
glorifiera la musique vénérera et par la
danse
glorifiera
pour ton sommeil tu attendras que le
soleil soit déjà là ton uniforme ne
changera basket t-shirt et jeun étroit
ta guitare ne quittera même quandit
t'accueillera toutes les filles tu
dragueras ta liberté préservera ton
jewinggum ne collera que sur les disques
de che là ta moto respectera pour
qu'elle t'emène où tu voudras l'argent
de poche que tu auras à t'éclater te
servira toutes tes amis dépannera pour
LESISS sortir des mauvais pas enfin à
toi tu
penseras car on le
vit tu le
vois c'est la loi
[Musique]
quiourouru grand rembl pour tous les
copains
less je suis le de la musique je viens
vers
toi pour
lui my je croise en
[Musique]
toi
jour ici un
jour c'est la lo il faud la respecter
tu AUD grand REM pourous less les et les
grands
[Musique]
la
verourhui
nousmem
commandement si tu nes pas vraiment
d'accord on va voir ailleurs
je suis le chef de cette bande qui joue
pour toi pr pour lui j'ai les pointsures
mais le cœur tendre pour mes
amis pour lui je suis sû de prêcher la
vérité comme moi il prêché
Aué c'est la loi il nous fut dans la
respecter si tu veux demain côé nous
sommes dans aujourd'hui le grand
rassemblement pour tous les toopins les
Cotis les grands c'est la loi qui te
Roure la respectecter tu verras t demain
que tout peut changer aujourd'hui nous
sommes qure le mêous seons S à chanter
ensemble nous dit
commandement mais si tu n'es pas
vraiment d'accord on va voir ailleurs
ailleurs ailleurs
[Musique]
ailleursol pr pour
nous
pr pour
[Applaudissements]
nous sur le bois de nos guitares ils
sont
gravés pour il surviv à notrepart il
sontrés pour t Chem prés pouri
command mais tu attendras que le soleil
soit déjà là ton uniforme ne changera
basket t-shirt et jein est droit ta
guitar ne quittera même quand ta lit
t'accueillera toutes les filles tu
dragueras ta liberté préservera t
shingum ne collera que sur les disques
de Ch ta moto respectera pour qu'elle
t'emmène où tu voudras l'argent de poche
que tu auras à t'éclater te servira tous
tes amis dépannera pour les sortir des
mauvais pas enfin à toi tu
penseras car on ne
vit qu'un foi
[Applaudissements]
c'est la
loi tu
veras que demain tout peut
[Musique]
changer
c'était en quelque sorte un Blanco
spiritual c'est un Blanco spiritual oui
verm non pas de publicité pour les AP
également notre cadeau de Noël oui c'est
un joli cadeau c'est c'est très joli si
j'ai bien compris c'est un cantique avec
batterie et orchestre c'est ça pour
batterie et grand orchestre et bien
puisque nous sommes il son ils sont très
pressés pourquoi parce qu'ils vont à
l'Olympia là main un peu ce soir vous
allez à l'Olympia bah mes enfants on je
ne vous dirai pas ce qu'on dit dans ces
caslà mais je le pense dir l'ORE
transmettra voilà on applaudit très très
fort les Martin Circus qui nous ont fait
l'amitié de venir dans fa pas mon outil
de
travail alors au revoir à très bientôt à
très bientôt alors on vous invite pas à
voir le pot traditionnel non parce qu'on
a rien et bien mesdames et messieurs je
vais vous demander maintenant
d'applaudir très très fort notre chef
d'orchestre Monsieur Pierre
porte
P qui ce soir va être mis à rue
d'épreuves puisqu'il va accompagner le
plus pénible des chanteurs oh non
c'est-à-dire moi-même nous allonsons
pensé que c'était Noël qu' fallait que
nous fassions un effort oui et nous
allons nous attaquer je dis bien nous
attaquer en espérant que ce ne sera pas
en traîre moi aussi non vous restez
tranquille moi si vous venez à mon
secours si la fou manifeste accompagné
par Pierre porte si vous le voulez bien
parce que c'est Noël peux l'annoncer
allez-y l'Avé
Maria de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
choubert
mar
Reine des
Cieux vers toi
célève ma
prière je dois trouver grâce à tes
yeux c'est en toi Viège sainte en
toi que
j'espère fils consolé ma
mis il souffrait là cé
mourant
comprends mes pleurs toi qui fumes
mère
rends-moi rends-moi mon pauvre
enfant
ave Marie
[Musique]
Ave
Maria
mon fils est
beau
de lui je suis déjà r
fier
P son modeste
Berau c'est mon bien mon unique
bien sur la
terre si Dieu ma frappe en sa
[Musique]
colère
du moin
innocent
exauce à moi c'est un
père qui veut mourir pour son
enfant
[Musique]
Marie
Ave
[Musique]
Maria à sa
prè
qu'une brillante
fleur tout bien fait ton chante Moné sa
[Musique]
mystère regard de moi pour que
j'espère mon fils ton front est
souriant
merci merci divine
mère c'est toi qui sauve mon
enfant
ave
Marie
très très
beau je le connaissais par CH Oui qui
était très bien mais alors celui-là est
encore mieux ah mais on peut vous le
faire on peut vous le faire par asnavour
on peut vous le faire par qui vous
voulez non non mais celui-là est superbe
ah ben c'est très joli c'est c'est
disons ce qu'on appelle en TER c'est
assez se gueule oui
oui je ne sais pas ce qu' avait Chout
j'ai pas envie d'essayer vous voulez pas
bon alors nous enchaînons nous revenons
c'est Noël c'est Noël et nous avons
mesdames messieurs voulu faire quelque
chose d'exceptionnel mais pour cela un
peu d'histoire et un peu d'histoire de
la télévision il y a 2 ans Philippe
Bouvard présentait une grande émission
de variété au théâtre 102 et dans cette
émission de variété il y avait un garçon
champion du monde de trampoline ce
garçon c'est c'est c'est Richard tison
c'est en France on a pas tellement de
champion du monde alors quand on en a
dans certaines spécialités faut bien se
rappeler leur nom c'est charartison un
garçon qui qui vraiment a énormément de
mérite et de talent et qui ce jour-là ce
jour-là une une catastrophe un incident
ça arrive Richard tison tombe du
trampoline il est
blessé mais très très vite il se remet
debout c'est un jeune garçon c'est un
sportif seulement voilà à part à partir
de ce jour-là les producteurs de
télévision ont peur ils ne veulent plus
passer Richard tison ils ont peur que
l'incidence renouvelle c'est un exercice
beaucoup trop dangereux et ça fait de la
peine à Richard tison parce que Richard
tison voudrait faire connaître le
trampoline en en France voudrait qu'il y
ait davantage adadte alors il est venu
nous trouver c'est un ami de Stéphane et
nous nous avons pris le risque nous
avons pris le risque parce que nous
savons que Richard artison a du talent
et en le somme il n'y a pas de risque
quand on a du talent comme Richard
titison il n'y a pas de risque je crois
qu'on a surtout on a surtout mesuré le
risque c'est qu'on a pris toutes les
précautions nécessaires pour que tout se
passe très très bien donc c'est un
exercice spectaculaire exécuté par le
Champion du Monde français Richard
tison
[Applaudissements]
laiss quelques secondes à Richard tion
pour récupérer car il s'agit d'un effort
beaucoup plus violent qu'on l'imagine et
il va nous exécuter un exercice encore
plus difficile et
puis c'est une première pour Richard ce
soir alors nous sommes avec toi on
applaudit à nouveau très très fort notre
champion du
monde
[Applaudissements]
bravo
et bien Richard merci c'est une preuve
de courage il fallait couper le signe
indien comme on dit dans notre
profession bravo de l'avoir fait ce soir
on va l'applaudir très très
[Applaudissements]
fort J qui nous chante un personnage de
WT Disney Charlotte
[Applaudissements]
Julien
[Musique]
Walt Disney comme
j'aimerais je vivrai dans un monde
enchanté je saurai danseri Doui Doui
loin de la grisaille décité je
gamberai le lapin bouant torette avec
moi dans les
bois la
la la fin la
la très bien
[Musique]
la là il
vousou oh et soudain au détour d'un
Fouret je
rencontrerai
ce bon prince charmant que j'ai chanté
un jour et que j'attends
toujours
lapin très
[Musique]
bien
hibou hibou c'est vous je serai une
gentille fée je vous vous
offrirai tous les cadeaux et tous les
jouets que vous
souhaiterien comme dans tous les rêves
dorés je
m'envolerai en semement des étoiles
d'argent derrière moi
sur
toi la
peou
regarde
c'est
j'installerai dans un carrosse blanc
tous les petits
enfants je les
emmènerai au pays de la
joie
avec moi
au revoir joyeux Noël à
tous
bravo ravi de te de te revoire plôt de
te découvrir de t'accueillir puis que
c'est la prière fois qu'and tu acccueill
la musique à musique oui c'est la toute
première fois alors quelle impression et
bien ça fait une grande
impression le cœur bat très fort et on
manque de souffle ah oui c'est ce qu' a
le plus terrible je ne sais pas pourquoi
vous nous faites manquer d'air et
malheureusement on perd de ses moyens
mais non elle a pas perdu ses moyens la
PR c'est que le public a applaudi très
fort et va le
[Applaudissements]
refaire Charlotte tu vas t'asseoir à
côté de notre champion du monde tu
verras c'est un monsieur qui peut
t'emmener haut dans le ciel bah oui
imaginez imaginez un petit peu le mar il
peut lui servir de trempelin non le
trempelin en plus imagine le mariage de
Richard TI
voulez vous prendre pour
épouse compte faudra il faudra qu'il
fasse ça dans une cathédrale à
ressort bon et bien
derrière Charlotte Julian en coulisse je
regarde s'il est là oui il est là et
c'est quelqu'un que vous allez appir
très fort Jo
DIN
tu passes dans mes insomni comme un
soleil de
nuit tu es le visage inconnu du paradis
perdu
Mar Maria sans tes yeux sans ton corps
sans ta voix
Maria
Maria je ne suis que la moitié de moi je
voudrais me lever je voudrais te toucher
et je sais que tu n'es pas très loin et
qu'au fond de mes nuits tu m'attends toi
aussi mais c'est long la moitié du
[Musique]
chemin
Mar
mar Mar Mar
Mar je ne suis que la moitié de
moi je ne retrouve le matin que le gris
cootidien tu disparais dans les fumées
de la
réalité
Maria
Maria sans tes yeux sans ton col sans ta
voix
Maria
Maria je ne suis que la moitié de
moi je te cherche partout comm un chien
comm un fou et je sais que tu n'es pas
très loin et qu'au fond de tes nuits tu
m'attends toi aussi mais c'eston la
moitié du
[Musique]
chemin
je te cherche partout comme un chien
comme un fou et je sais que tu n'es pas
très loin et qu'au fond de tes nuits tu
m'attends toi aussi mais c'eston la
moitié du chemin
Maria
Maria sans tes yeux sans ton corps sans
ta VO
Maria
Maria je ne suis que la moitié de
moi Mar Mar Mar Mar Maria
Maria Maria Maria Maria Maria Mar Maria
[Musique]
mar
[Applaudissements]
élégant comme ça attendez monsieur
Jassin tiens je vais te faire un très
beau cadeau de
Noël voilà Stan j c'est la première fois
que nous t'accueillons aussi à musican
musique c'est la vérité strict où est-ce
qu'on planque ça par et bien ça je ne
sais pas en principe ça se met là mais
comme c'est à stéan il vaut mieux le lui
rendre soit le bienvenu ici et puisque
tu termines la soirée avec nous non ça
c'est celui-là il marche pas non
celui-là il marche pas du tout non parce
que ça se met dans les narines ça c'est
méd nazale voilà exactement tu
t'installes à côté de nos amis puisque
nous aurons le plaisir de t'entendre
tout à l'heure d'accord je Stan bois
tranquillement regarde passer les
passants comme on dit dans faost mon
cher Stéphane oui vous avez certainement
reçu à l'âge de 8 ans un petit livre
dessiné illustré par son
auteur le petit prince de oui comme je
crois qu'il n'y a pas un jeune petit
français ou une petite française qui à
un moment de son enfance nlu le petit
prince de
saintexupéri on vient même de
l'enregistrer on en a fait un disque
avec une distribution
étincelante et nous allons retrouver ce
soir le petit prince interprété par
Jean-Claude mot au moment où ce petit
prince rencontre le renard le renard dit
des choses très profondes sur les hommes
le renard connaît bien les hommes vous
vous rappelez de l'histoire du Petit
Prince c'est un soir un aviateur qui
tombe en panne dans le seint
Hara et brusquement il se retourne il y
a là un petit
prince ainsi commence le petit prince de
saintexupérie qui va de planète en
planète et là il rencontre le renard et
le renard ce soir sera interprété par un
immense comédien qui nous a fait
l'honneur et l'amitié de venir passer ce
musique en musique avec nous c'est
Monsieur Claude Dauphin Jean-Claude
Millot et Claude Dauphin dans un extrait
du Petit Prince
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
saint-exupéri
bonjour bonjour Qui
es-tu je suis un renard viens jouer avec
moi je suis tellement triste euh je ne
puis pas jouer avec toi je ne suis pas
d'privoisé ah pardon h qu'est-ce que
signifie
appruoisé tu n'es pas d'ici que
cherches-tu je cherche les hommes
qu'est-ce que signifie
apprivoisé les hommes ils ont des fusils
et ils chassent c'est bien gênant mais
ils élèvent aussi des poules c'est leur
seul
intérêt
tu tu cherches des poules non des amis
ah qu'est-ce que signifie appruoisé oh
c'est une chose trop oubliée ça ça
signifie créer des liens créer des liens
ah bien sûr tu n'es encore pour moi
qu'un petit garçon tout semblable à
100000 petits garçons et j'ai pas besoin
de toi et tu n'as pas besoin de moi je
ne suis pour toi qu' un renard semblable
à 100000 renards mais si tu m'ap
privoise nous aurons besoin l'un de
l'autre tu seras pour moi unique au
monde et je serai pour toi unique au
monde je commence à comprendre ah il y a
une fleur je crois qu'elle m'a privoisé
ah
c'est bien possible on voit sur la terre
toutes sortes de choses oh c'est pas sur
la terre sur une autre planète oui ah il
y a des chasseurs sur cette planète là
non ah c'est intéressant ça et des des
poules non ah rien n'est
parfait ma ma vie est monotone je je
chasse les poules les hommes me chassent
toutes les poules se ressemblent et tous
les hommes se ressemblent je m'ennuie
donc un
peu s'il te
plaît apprivoise-moi je veux bien mais
je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps j'ai des
amis à découvrir et beaucoup de choses à
connaître ouis on ne connaît que les
choses que l'on a qu'on en appr privoise
les hommes n'ont plus le temps de rien
connaître ils assè des choses toutes
faites chez les marchands et comme il
n'existe point de marchands d'amis les
hommes n'ont plus
d'amis si tu veux un ami
apprivoise-moi que faut-il faire oh il
faut être très patient tu tu t'assoeras
d'abord un peu plus loin de moi comme ça
dans l'herbe alors je te regarderai du
coin de l'œil ah non non tu ne diras
rien le langage est une source de
malentendu mais chaque jour tu pourras
t'asseoir un peu plus
près le lendemain revint le petit prince
il aurait mieux valu que tu reviennes à
la même
heure bon si tu arrives par exemple à à
4h de l'après-midi dès 3h je commencerai
d'être heureux plus l'heure avancera
plus je me sentirai heureux hein et
puis des 3 des 4 heures déjà je je
m'agiterai je m'inquiéterai je
découvrirai le le prix du
bonheur mais si tu viens n'importe quand
je ne saurai jamais à quelle
heure m'habiller le cœur ainsi le Petit
Prince a pris voisin le
renard je te fais cadeau d'un secret
il est très
simple on ne voit bien qu'avec le cœur
l'essentiel est invisible pour les yeux
ouais oui c'est le temps que tu as perdu
pour ta rose qui fait ta rose si
importante c'est le le temps que j'ai
perdu pour ma
rose les hommes ont oublié cette vérité
mais tu ne dois pas l'oublier tu deviens
pour toujours responsable de ce que tu
as
apprivoisé tu es responsable de ta rose
je suis responsable de ma rose je suis
responsable de ma rose tu es responsable
de ta rose je suis responsable de ma
rose
monsieur dauphin merci d'avoir
interprété je vous en plusis ce texte
merveilleux remerci vous savez je peux
vous rter un tout petit souvenir très
rapidement Voilà il se trouve que en
1935 je crois il y avait un une
exposition d'avion au Bourget et il y
avait un on inauguré un nouvel avion de
transport pour l'Angleterre je crois et
je faisais de la radio à ce moment-là je
tenais un micro comme vous et j'avais
réussi à faire venir sur cet avion pour
être interviewé euh
saint-exupéri et
jeanmermos ça faisait un joli équipage
oui alors il y avait tous les
photographes qui étaient là et ils se
sont assis dans au poste d'équipage ils
se sont amusés à faire marcher les les
commandes et tout ça il riait beaucoup
il faisait beaucoup de bêtises ces deux
Archanges C grands hommes et puis
brusquement ils sont regardés et ils se
sont arrêtés de rire mais l'espace de 10
secondes peut-être ils sont devenus très
sérieux et puis ils ont recommencé à à
faire marcher les les machines à
s'amuser et puis un an après où je crois
à peu près mermose a disparu dans dans
l'Atlantique du Sud et plusieurs années
après ça a été le tour de saint-exupéri
qui lui a disparu dans le ciel de la
Méditerranée et et le petit prince avait
paru à ce moment-là et quand j'ai lu le
petit prince j'ai pensé que ce jour-là
au Bourget dans cet avion où il
s'amusait tant quand c'était arrêté de
rire ils avaient vu le petit prince et
que le petit prince était là qui les
regardait et qui attendait pour les
emmener dans sa planète en tout cas
s'ils sont l'un et l'autre dans la
planète du Petit Prince ils ne sont pas
malheureux merci et bravo Monsieur
Claude
[Applaudissements]
Dauphin
pe envisager mon cher Stéphan de
célébrer la fête de Noël en France sans
interpréter petit papa noël c'est pas
pensable il n'y a pas de famille pas de
foyer français dans lequel cette chanson
n'est droit de citer la chante oh oui
même moi et là nous avons une interprète
une interprète qui a renouvelé cette
chanson qui a réussi à la renouveler et
ça n'était pas facile derilleère
monsieur tinorossi avec une voix que
nous lui connaissons une trèss très
jolie voix beaucoup de charme voici
Petit Papa
Noël par Michel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Thor
c'est la belle nuit de Noël la neige
étend son manteau blanc et les yeux
levés vers le ciel AGENOU les petits
enfants avant de fermer les
paupières font une dernière
prière Petit
Papa
Noël
quand tu
descendras du
ciel
avec des jouets par
milers n'oublie pas mon petit
souis mais avant de
partir il faudra bien te
couvrir
de tu vas avoir si proi c'est un peu à
cause de
moi il me tarde tempant que le jour se
lève pour voir si tu m'as
[Musique]
apporté tous les beaux joujou que je
vois quand rêve et que je t'ai
commandé Petit Papa
Noël quand tu
descendras
duciel
avec des jouets
parmi n'oublie pas mon petit
soulier le marchand de sable est passé
les enfants vont faire dodo et tu vas
pouvoir commencer à des cahotes sur le
dos au son des cloches des
églises ta distribution de
surprise Petit Papa
Noël quand tu
descendras du
ciel
avec des jouets
parmliers
n'oublie pas mon petit
souier mais avant de
partir il faudra bien te
couvrir
deh tu vas avoir si
froid c'est un peu à cause de
moi et quand tu seras sur ton beau nuage
viens d'abord sur notre
maison je n'ai pas été tous les jours
très sage je t'en demande
pardon Petit Papa
Noël quand tu
descendras du
ciel
des jouets
PARM n'oublie pas mon petit
souign
petit
[Musique]
papa n accueillons pour la première fois
aussi un musique à musique soit la
bienvenue c'était magnifique bravo merci
Jacques merci ne chante pas du tout
comme Tino non
c'est tout à fait différent je crois oui
oui oui mais mon Dieu si le si le succès
pouvait -être aussi grand mais oui je
crois qu'il a assuré les 35 premières
années à toi d'assurer les 35 autres oh
là là pourvu que tu dise vrai on on
applaudit très très fort Michel
Thor voilà al il nous
fautur dauphin je vous la confie voilà
le petit prince et la princesse voyez
comme vous êtes bien placé et nous
allons demander à notre ami J d'in de
nous faire son cadeau de Noël et son
cadeau de Noël c'est une autre chanson
Jassin une nouvelle chanson
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle dans son quartier du Vieux
Québec les rues ont l'air d'avoir
[Musique]
l'accent et l'an 2000 voisine avec les
maisons grises du vieux
temps mais l'hiver vient d'éclater le
Saint-Laurent est prisonnier d'un
décembre qui va bien durer 6
mois quand les joursessemblons lui sans
éclairciir à espérer qui peut croire que
l'été nous
reviendra moi j'avais le sole et jour et
nuit dans les yeux
d'Émilie je réchauffé ma vie à son
sourire Mo j'is le sole et nuit et jour
dans les yeux de la
et la
mélancholie au soleil
démirie dans les joies de
vivre dans son quartier du Vieux Québec
quand les rudes deviennent
vert quand les enfants ont les pieds
secs on tourne le dos à
[Musique]
l'hiver c'est la fête du printemp le
grand retour du Saint-Laurent on dirait
que les gens sortent de la
[Musique]
terre mais Émilie n'est plus à moi j'ai
froid pour la première fois je n'ai plus
ni sa chaleur ni sa
lumière
j'avis le soleil et nuit dans les yeux
d'
j'chauffé ma vie à son
sourirei
j'avis le sol et nuit et jour dans les
yeux de
Laou et la
mélancolie au soleil des
l les joies de vivre en ce temps-là
j'avais le sang et jour et nuit dans les
yeux
desm je réchauffé ma vie à son
sourire j'is le sole et jour dans les
yeux de
l'amour et la
mélancolie au soleil
des dev des joies de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Vire merci Jo et bien mesdames messieurs
Noël la fête des enfants je l' mien en
effet il y a 1 an il me demandaiit
d'être leurs parins et j'avoue que
j'étais très flatté qui il et bien les
artistes des cœurs de l'Opéra de
Paris ces artistes sont parmi les
meilleurs compte parmi les meilleurs du
monde et ils ont formé un ensemble qui
porte le nom de l'architecte qui a
construit l'Opéra de Paris c'est
l'ensemble Garnier l'ensemble Garnier
est constitué en effet des artistes des
cœurs de l'Opéra de Paris ils sont venus
passer ce dimanche de Noël avec nous et
nous allons les accueillir très très
fort moi en tant que Parin ils étaient
venu lors de la première émission de
music and music il avaient chanter
nabouo oui je m'en souviens et nous
accueillons maintenant très fort
l'ensemble vocal
carnier
[Musique]
Jésus
VO du
ciel
les
v
[Musique]
nous
n et je
dans de
[Musique]
chist
tous Je
nous il SAA
[Musique]
nous
toile nous so
gué
[Musique]
jusons
annoncer les
propètes
[Musique]
sain
Jésus du
cielver
nous
[Musique]
sauver
est
cette
[Musique]
nuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tr